dans un brésil / la politique de jacques
bolson araud la cour suprême a décidé ce
lundi d'annuler l'ensemble des
condamnations de l'ancien président lula
un véritable coup de tonnerre dans la
sphère politique brésilienne luiz inacio
lula da silva retrouve donc ses droits
politiques est désormais éligible pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 la
décision qui affirme aujourd'hui
l'incompétence de la justice fédérale de
curitiba et la reconnaissance du fait
que nous avons toujours eu raison dans
cette longue bataille juridique le juge
hudson feutchine de la cour suprême a
estimé que le tribunal de curitiba était
je cite pas compétent pour juger des
affaires de l'ancien président pour
rappel lula avait été condamné dans
quatre procès notamment pour des
affaires de corruption
ces derniers mois les condamnations
contre luiz inacio lula da silva avait
été discréditée par le site il
intercepte brasil la partialité des
juges et procureurs avaient notamment
été mise en doute
le tribunal fédéral de brasilia statuera
sur les affaires de l'ancien chef d'état
si l'éligibilité de lula est vue d'un
bon oeil par le parti des travailleurs
le président jaillir wolson a rhône
était pas ravie de la décision de la
cour suprême sur cnn brésil
le chef d'état a affirmé que le juge
chin avait je cite toujours eu des liens
étroits avec le parti des travailleurs
en aucun cas un homme ne peut être
maître de ce jugement
la bourse a baissé et le dollar a
augmenté nous avons tous souffert d'une
décision comme celle-là
maintenant nous espérons que la cour
suprême rétablira les jugements dans la
population
la nouvelle a également beaucoup fait
réagir à rio dé janeiro
les brésiliens a semblé partagés quant à
l'avenir politique de luiz inacio lula
da silva
c'est une bonne nouvelle qui arrive au
bon moment car la situation politique
dans le pays est tellement désastreuse
dramatique s'il revenait au pouvoir je
le soutiendrai parce qu'il a les
compétences pour le faire
c'est un bon président
je ne peux pas croire en un homme
politique qui a déjà été arrêté pour
corruption
et je ne pense pas qu'il serait la bonne
personne pour diriger notre pays
ball sonar ou lula la course à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 semble d'ores
et déjà lancée selon les sondages 50%
des personnes interrogées se disent
prêtes à voter en faveur de mollahs
contre 44% projet un vol ce barreau